so there's no Knockouts there's no like
no knock down real fighting so it's an
actual exhibition Tyson versus Roy yeah
yeah no and that's also not gonna sell
at all yeah at all hey come check out
these guys like move around a little bit
dude that's the worst thing they could
do yeah it's gonna be an awful mistake
for Francis man when you leave the UFC
think you're gonna get this big fight
like we'll do it but we can't actually
hit each other they'd be better off
doing the WWE like you get more eyeballs
that fan base knows the deal they train
for it they look good you get that WWE
fan base doing a fake boxing match it's
it's going to turn all fight fans off
yeah so you're not getting that support
WWE fans won't give a mess we're
doing WWE if you're gonna fake it
honestly I would rather watch Elon Musk
and Mark Zuckerberg's fight then this is
insane then Tyson fear and Francine got
to do a fake box to match